[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Guardians
Deputy political editor Jessica elgot
and the times home Affairs editor Matt
dathan they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the guardian has an exclusive
reporting that the health secretary
Steve Barkley has privately acknowledged
the government will need to increase its
payoffer to nurses
Millions more offered chance to take
statins takes the front page of the
times as new NHS guidelines could help
Millions ward off heart attacks and
strokes
the Metro carries claims of sexual
contact between attendees at the Downing
Street parties during lockdown Sky News
has asked a number 10 for comment
the financial times reports the U.S
attorney general Merrick Garland has
appointed a special counsel to
investigate the presence of classified
documents on President Joe Biden's
private property unlike Donald Trump
Biden's lawyers returned the files
promptly and are cooperating with the
investigation
the eye leads with research showing that
34 homeless children in England died
over a three-year period
the telegraph understands the government
intends to ban gas boilers in the next
10 years in an effort to achieve Net
Zero carbon emissions
the mirror leads with an exclusive the
headline Heroes cancer treatment as
firefighters at grenful have since been
diagnosed with cancer in some cases
terminal
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Jessica elgot and Matt dathan welcome to
you both let's start off by having a
look at this uh exclusive from the
guardian um they're suggesting that uh
Steve Barkley the health secretary is
admitting that he will have to increase
the payoffer to NHS workers that is a
watch you probably would class as a
U-turn Jessica
yeah and I think that there is I think
there's actually an acceptance across
government now that there will have to
be a look at 2022-23 which is very very
different to what they were saying
before Christmas uh in the form of a
one-off payment or potentially back
dating the settlement
um that they agreed to in April
um to um January so they get a sort of
an extra chunk of that uplift
um the the issue that Steve Bach has got
is the treasury is not getting any new
money for this so this is something that
they have to find
um out of existing uh NHS budgets and
existing NHS plus it's a very very tight
and I think that there's some skepticism
across the sector about whether that's
whether that is possible whether it's
you know the 2-3 billion which
apparently will be for for them to offer
around a million workers this improved
deal
um you know that will be quite that'll
be quite difficult
um for them to get out of the existing
budget so they're off the NHS yes a mat
according to the senior sources who have
spoken to the guardian Steve Barclays
acknowledged that more than a million
Frontline Personnel deserve more money
and that's after months of him
repeatedly saying that there is no more
money
yeah it's quite the U-turn from Steve
Barkley um I mean he was in the run up
to Christmas um the ministers would
um repeatedly lay out just how much it
would cost if a ministers were to cave
in to individual Union demands and you
do wonder that if the government does
start
um I guess uh compromising on with
nurses are they going to start
compromising
um with other striking workers as well
the shift really started to come at the
weekend when Rishi sunak gave an
interview
um refusing to rule out uh going back to
this Current financial Year's pay uh and
and all through this week there's been a
slow steady sort of expectation that the
government wood cave and this story
confirms it that there's a source quite
right at the end of that front page
story saying ministers are intent on
preventing further NHS strikes which
obviously they've been trying to do
throughout but the key to this is they
add that they understand that they all
have to be the offer of extra support on
the table for 20 22-23 but as Jess it
lays out that Jeremy Hunt is very
uncompromising and saying that uh Steve
Barkley will have to find up to three
billion pounds of savings elsewhere in
the social care budget or the NHS budget
uh and Jessica where where is the money
likely to to come from do you think
so you know he can find it out of his
own Department of Health budget but more
very much more likely it's likely to
come out of NHS England's budget and I
think NHS England has already you know
laid the groundwork for warnings about
this and saying you know if they if
they're expecting to find you know three
billion two to three billion pounds of
efficiency savings that's really for the
birds and and that what it will mean is
effects on Frontline services and I
think when we're already seeing
um you know what what what pressures
Frontline services are under
um finding that kind of money
um you know for NHS England is going to
be very difficult and and
um you know I suppose the next Frontier
will be is if as if Steve Barkley says
he can't find
um this money and then what and then
what happens after that um I mean you've
already heard him tried to sort of lay
the groundwork for this in talks with
um Union officials on Monday where he
was a repeatedly stressing things about
efficiencies and and trying to
um you know increase productivity in in
various parts of the NHS now whether
that's you know through trying to cut
Administration I don't think you know
that I think there was a bit of a bad
reaction to that because essentially
what people can interpret that is that
NHS staff aren't working hard enough I
think more broadly what it means is
trying to find places where work is
being duplicated or work you know
there's too much Administration in work
and whether that can kind of be
tightened up um
but you know whether there's three
billion pounds worth of that I think is
is you know very unclear at this stage
uh Matt it does seem as though it's
going to require the health secretary to
to rob peter in order to pay Paul
yeah it doesn't um I think with NHS uh
bosses like Matthew Taylor consistently
saying uh how damaging strikes have been
over Christmas he's now going to be
um the center of attention to see how he
fights back I guess um as all the other
NHS bosses are and uh it's just um I
mean it's it's very interesting that
you've got Jeremy Hunt being so uncom
uncompromising in the treasury but you'd
wonder how much influence actually when
she sunak has given his uh formal role
as Chancellor
to the Metro Jessica and we read that
makeshift morgues are being opened
across the UK to deal with a backlog of
deaths over the winter months
um there's another uh problem occurring
as the the NHS is struggling
yeah and we saw those figures come out a
couple of days ago that about 35 000
additional people have died you know
more than expected in the last six
months
um and that's I think about 10 10 11
more than than you'd see usually see
over five years
um and that's but you have to take out
that the sort of covid affected you know
the big covid spikes you saw in 2020 but
um you know some of those excess deaths
is is not 100 clear why that might be
the case you know or obviously we've
seen I think a bit of a surge in flu and
and in some other viruses but also you
know the thing that people will be
worrying about is are we seeing these
excess tests because you know we're
seeing um those deaths occur mostly at
home rather than in hospitals or Care
Homes and you and and of course then
people start to speculate whether that
means that people aren't getting to
hospital they aren't getting to
ambulances maybe they're delaying
treatment because they're concerned
about the state of the NHS and
um and now of course some of the
consequence of this is that you know
morgue so don't have the capacity to to
um hold enough people who've who've
sadly died well the article is saying
that temporary sites have been open to
cope with an estimated extra 4 000
deaths with a combination of flu covid
and a and d delays blamed so a e does
seem to to factor in the the picture map
yeah that's right and what's quite
astonishing in this article is uh this
this sort of a temporary sites that
councils have had to open like a um a
gritting yard in um uh Salisbury and
Wiltshire
um in northamptonshire they've opened a
former landfill site that's operating as
a temporary morgue which was used during
the pandemic and it just sort of reminds
us of those uh horrific images and uh
forecasts that we had three years ago um
at the start of the covet pandemic just
um the the uh I guess the Urgent and
emergency
contingency plans that council's having
to take as they see excess deaths
yeah that one of the
areas being used former landfill site in
Wollaston the site manager there saying
that um he actually wanted to bring
Anonymous but saying the mortuary can
hold up to 200 bodies and we will stay
open as long as we're required to do so
which will probably be and just another
six weeks he's quoting let's move on to
the telegraph uh hopefully an end to the
rail strikes do we think Jessica
there's certainly some a lot more
positive noises coming out of those
negotiations than we've seen you know
definitely in recent weeks there there
we've had talks uh today between the rmt
and the tssa unions with the rail
delivery group so with operators rather
than with the government and there is a
new there seems to be a new offer on the
table they you know they've put out very
kind of passive statements that say
they're working jointly towards the
revised offer the discussions continuing
you know that isn't the kind of far in
Brimstone that we've heard
um from from General secretaries like
Mick Lynch over the past few months so
that suggests that there's a deal that
they don't want to to blow up and and
that they're interested in
um earlier in the week we and others
reported that the government ministers
were sort of prepared to quietly drop
some of the things that they'd asked for
which is for these um driver only
operated uh trains to be part of the
deal and part of some of the reforms and
that's something that the unions are
really really deeply opposed to and
again that's kind of smoothed the way I
think
um towards there being a deal and I
think one of the really important things
about the the rail deal is that whatever
they decide for next year's settlement
which is um you know part of the pay
agreement will be like a certain amount
of increase over the next two years we
think about 9.5 percent
um is that it will actually it will set
a bar for a lot of these other disputes
so whatever they agree with the rail
unions very likely it's going to be
similar to what they they agree with
lots of the other
um uh different industries that are
going on strike yeah Downing Street uh
hoping that the rmt will agree to a deal
on Monday uh there's going to be a
meeting of Union Executives but settling
with the rmt wouldn't end all the the
train strikes aslev still threatening
industrial action Matt
yeah that's right and has left um I've
got a mandate that's slightly longer
than um the rmt I think until June so
um they could if they wanted to uh to
strike up until then
um and uh yaslev who represented more of
the train drivers
um but it is um it is very optimistic in
the Telegraph and uh it's not just real
um disputes but it's also teacher
dispute the first teaching Union uh who
voted uh this week didn't get enough
um of their members voting I think at
least 42 voted to them they needed a
threshold of 50 to vote
um I think 90 of those who did vote
actually backed industrial action but uh
it's a it's a good it's a good um a
development for the government but
obviously there's I think at least two
other teaching Union unions who are
going to be voting next week
um so I mean there's some good news in
the after weeks if well if not months of
uh disruption across public services but
um it's a question of what cost it will
come and I guess which side is going to
win
Jessica and the guardian Boris Johnson
is planning a trip to Ukraine to visit
president uh solenski
yes so um obviously we know that
um Boris Johnson's been a huge backer of
Ukraine he's very popular there
um and I think that that's you know you
know obviously he's very keen to kind of
keep the Ukraine on the on the agenda
and to keep it in the news and took and
also I think because you know it's it's
part of his you know reputation in
government that he's quite proud of
um so we we know that this um visit is
going ahead my colleague is reporting on
that but um you know I think there are
and there are concerns I think some of
the concerns in the piece when people
quoted in the piece that you know it's
it's really important that that Johnson
doesn't um you know in any way undermine
the relationship between Ukraine and the
current you know in Russia and the
current number 10 and not kind of
interfere with the messaging or the kind
of official lines of communication and
it's um it's Tobias Elwood who's the
chair of this event select committee
saying that in the um in the in the
piece and there's some others who are a
bit more Anonymous saying you know know
saying he's trying to have this his
Churchill moment and and the situation
there is is pretty fragile so he really
needs to be careful not to in any way
compromise if she's the enacts
relationship with zelenski Ukrainian
sources sayings no uh concrete
information yet on date Jessica and Matt
thank you very much for the moment we
are going to take a break coming up Joe
Biden is accused of improperly handling
classified documents to explore the
similarities and differences between the
claims made against Donald Trump
foreign
[Music]
let us have a look at the uh Financial
Times and this story about President
Biden who's now facing an investigation
um remind us of the story first of all
Matt
the
discovery of confidential documents and
material from when Joe Biden was vice
president and Barack Obama originally
there were documents found by his
lawyers at the Penn Center a uh in
Washington and following that his
lawyers searched his home in Wilmington
and found even more documents from his
time as vice president in his garage
this brought obviously comparisons with
the whole Donald Trump Affair but I
think that there is quite a lot of
differences
um a on the
quantitative material far less found
um in Biden's case and um and B also
Trump's team obviously have stopped um
the let's to stop the release of these
documents um and uh Biden's team have
been cooperating with them and Biden
seems in quite uh he's sort of brushed
it aside he's he's not taking it too
seriously by the sounds of it at the
moment
um he was joking how um he keeps his car
are locked in the garage so it's it's
very secure location but it's obviously
um raised some really very serious
questions about uh protection of
national security by a sitting president
and um called into question whether
um he well I guess whether he might
rerun for
um the presidency a decision that he's
going to have to make quite soon do you
think that this is that that serious
well I think it's um with ft reports
that it comes at a time when his uh
approval ratings have been quite high
and this will obviously Dent
um his the public perception of Joe
Biden's um I guess his also raises
question over
um his uh uh his forgetfulness that has
been sort of played his time as
president
um and the seriousness to which he takes
National Security
um and it's coming at a quite an
important time when the party and he
decides whether whether to re-run for a
president just he does seem to appeared
quite flippant about it saying you know
by the way my Corvettes in a locked
garage it's not like the files are
sitting out on the street doesn't sound
very apologetic
no and I and I suspect that that's you
know uh you know well I sort of tactic
to play Down the the seriousness of it I
think it's quite it strikes me as quite
ironic that
um you know that there's there have been
these two quite serious security
breaches which have actually involved
physical documents because we've heard
so much over the past
um you know few years particularly here
about like
um people using personal email addresses
or using Whatsapp groups to talk about
um very sensitive information and for
these two presidents what they've
actually you know that they've covered
Cropper about has been like storing
files of paper in there in you know in
in Trump's case in his Florida
um sort of compound Mar-A-Lago and and
and and Joe Bryden in his garage so you
know in fact lots of it uh but lots of
it seems to be very un kind of you know
not very much the New Frontiers of tech
but actually you know people just just
keeping you know souvenirs that happen
to be very confidential documents
Republicans are complaining criticizing
Biden of double standards The Last Story
we're going to take a look at is uh
Prince and Princess of Wales they've
been out first time since Harry's
autobiography came out Matt
yeah that's right and obviously everyone
in the country wants to know what they
really think and feel in response to the
damaging Revelations that Harry has
written right in his book but obviously
they were not commenting on that when
asked about it on a visit to the
hospital in Liverpool I think the Metro
quotes one eight-year-old named Sylvia
who told William
um that keep going will scouters love
you so uh so it's telling the couple
that the public are very much on their
side but um
I guess I guess I'll have to talk about
it at some stage I I doubt they'll be
talking about it anytime soon but it'd
be fascinating once they do break their
silence yeah Jessica I was going to ask
that very question do you think we will
ever hear their side of the story
I think it's quite interesting because
obviously they did initially respond to
the Oprah interview they had that very
sort of famous line about Recollections
may vary and
um and William was actually sort of
goaded a bit into responding to it but
you know a shout with shouts across
about you know racist family and he says
we're not a racist family and this time
there's obviously a you know real
determination to completely ignore what
was said to to not respond to those kind
of shouted questions but inevitably at
some point one member of the royal
family who's featured in this book is
going to have to do an interview about
something and it's very difficult for
them to to completely ban any questions
about this I mean that would be
ludicrous so you know if Prince William
you know wants to or and and Kate want
to go on a tour somewhere and you know
or or promote one of their Charities
it's quite tricky yeah they do do
eventually speak Jessica and Matt thank
you very much see in the next hour